قال اوفير سوفير وزير الهجره والاستيعاب
الاسرائيلي عن حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه ان
تقديراته الشخصيه تشير الى ان الحرب في
غزه ستتواصل الى ما بعد العام الجاري وقد
تستمر حتى العام المقبل وربما حتى عام
2026 واضاف في مقابله مع اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان عمليه السور الواقي في
اشاره الى اجتياح الضفه الغربيه في
الانتفاضه الثانيه استغرقت سنوات عده
بينما تتطلب العمليات العسكريه في غزه
وقتا
اطول قال رئيس حزب اسرائيل بيتنا ان
نتنياهو يدير البلاد انطلاقا مما سماها
الاعتبارات الائتلافيه وان الامر الوحيد
الذي يهتم له هو الحفاظ على الائتلاف
الحكومي واضاف ان الوزيرين في مجلس الحرب
الاسرائيلي بيني جانس وجدي ايزنكوت يمنحان
الشرعيه لنتنياهو للتهرب من الحديث عن
اليوم التالي
للحرب تنظم الينا من تل ابيب مراسله
الجزيره نجوان سمري نجوان انطلاقا من
المواقف التي ذكرناها الان ما جديد ال
المواقف السياسيه في
تلبي نعم وسيله لو اردنا التطرق الى
التصريحات التي ادلى بها وزير الهجره
والاستيعاب عن حزب الصهيون
الدينيه صباح هذا اليوم فنحن نتحدث عن
واحد من اقطاب الاحزاب الاكثر تطرفا
ويميني في اسرائيل وهو من حزب الصهيونيه
الدينيه الذي يقوده بيتسل ايس موتر وعندما
قال صباح هذا اليوم لاذاعه الجيش بانه
يتوقع وفقا لتجاربه السابقه الشخصيه مع
عمليه السور الواقي في اشاره الى اجتياح
الضفه الغربيه في عام 2002 ابان الانتفاضه
الثانيه بان هذه العمليات ايضا في غزه
ستطول الى ما بعد هذا العام وربما تستمر
حتى عام
2026 هذا عمليا يمثل موقف اليمين واليمين
المتطرف في اسرائيل وفقا اولا لمصالحهم
الشخصيه
لامادا لاطاله امد هذه الحرب من جهه وانهم
يسعون ولديهم اهداف كانت ربما قبل هذه
الحرب مبطنه لكنها بدات تظهر للعلن خلال
هذه الحرب وهي اعاده الاستيطان الى غزه
كانت هناك المستوطنات التي تم اخلائها في
عام 2005 ضمن خطه الانفصال اليوم يجاهرون
اليمين المتطرف وعلى راسهم وزراء وكان قبل
يومين هناك مؤتمر علني شاركت به
الاحزاب المتطرفه برئاسه بن كفير تمار بن
كفير وزير الامن القومي لكن كانت ربما
المفاجاه على الاقل للجانب الاسرائيلي انه
شارك في هذا المؤتمر اعضاء ووزراء من حزب
الليكود الحاكم وهذا المؤتمر جاء تحت
عنوان اعاده الاستيطان في غزه وتهجير
الفلسطينيين من هناك وهذا ربما اثار ضجه
كبيره ايضا في اسرائيل على الاقل في هذه
المرحله بعد محكمه العدل الدوليه التي
طالبت اسرائيل بالتوقف عن مثل هذه
التصريحات العلنيه التي تشير بشكل واضح
الى حرب اباده والى تهجير وترانسفير لسكان
الفلسطينيين من غزه رغم ذلك عقد هذا
المؤتمر قبل يومين بشكل علني وهذا اليوم
يضيف هذا الوزير في حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه
بان الحرب ستتواصل لاكثر من عامين لان
العمليات العسكريه في غزه تتطلب وقتا اطول
مما كان مما تطلبته العمليات العسكريه في
عمليه السور الواقي عام
2002 بعد الاجتياح والعمليات المكثفه في
حينه انتقل الجيش الى عمليات محدوده وهذا
ما يطالب به ايضا زعيم هذا الحزب بيتسل
ايس موتتش وطله الوقت يهدد بانه في حال
اعلن نتنياهو عن عن وقف هذه الحرب حتى في
اطار اتمام صفقه فانه سينسحب من الحكومه
في مقابل ذلك ايضا وسيله هناك اليوم امر
هام يحدث في الكنيست في سابقه ربما في
تاريخ الكنيست يتم مناقشه بدات قبل قليل
في لجنه الكنيست لعزل احد النواب
اليساريين اي من حزب الجبهه الديمقراطيه
للسلام والمساواه عوفر كسيف هو نائب
اسرائيلي يمثل الجانب اليساري في الكنيست
اي بد منذ بدء الحرب بدا بالتعبير عن
مواقف قفه المناهضه لهذه الحرب على غزه
ووقع على عريضه تدعم الدعوه التي تقدمت
بها دوله جنوب افريقيا ضد اسرائيل بطلب
لوقف الاباده الجماعيه والحرب على غزه
ومنذ ذلك الحين شنت ضده حمله تحريض واسعه
وبادر احد الاعضاء من حزب اسرائيل بيتنا
المتطرف بزعامه ايضا ليبرمان ورغم ان هذا
الحزب حاليا ضمن صفوف المعارضه طالبوا ب
البدء باجراءات عزل هذا النائب وبالفعل
يعني عندما كان يجب ان يوقع 70 من اعضاء
الكنيست على عقد جلسه خاصه من اجل عزله
وقع عليها 87 عضوا من اصل 12 بمعنى انه
فقط ربما الاحزاب العربيه وبعض احزاب
المعارضه لم توقع على هذه العريضه ويوم
امس ايه عقدت هذه اللجنه جلستها الاولى
وهذا اليوم ستوقع على على عزله كليا ومره
اخرى هذا لم يحدث سابقا لم يحدث ان تم عزل
نائب في الكنيست بهذه الطريقه وعلى هذا
النحو بعد التصويت اليوم في حال صوت ثلاثه
ارباع اعضاء هذه اللجنه على عزل كثيف وهو
ما يتوقع سيحال ذلك الى الهيئه العامه
للتصويت عليه بعد نحو 10 ايام وحينها
سيصبح القرار نافذا حتى الان لم يعلن عفر
كسيف فيما اذا كان سيتوجه للمحكمه العليا
على الاغلب بانه سيتوجه لان هناك موقف
ابدته المستشاره القضائيه للحكومه
والمستشاره القضائيه للكنيست بانه لا يوجد
مسوغ قانوني وقضائي يتيح عزل عفر كسيف
وفقا للاتهامات التي توجه اليه بانه يدعم
المقاومه المسلحه او الكفاح المسلح ضد
اسرائيل من قبل المقاومه الفلسطينيه وهنا
نذكر انه منذ بدايه هذه الحرب تم قمع
واسكات اي صوت يخرج وينادي بوقف الحرب على
غزه وكل من نادى بوقف الحرب على غزه اتهم
بانه يدعم العمليات المسلحه ضد اسرائيل
حتى الاسرائيليين وعلى قلتهم وسيله نحن
نتحدث عن عدد قليل جدا يمثل اليسار
الاسرائيلي هذا اليوم سواء كان في الكنيست
في البرلمان او في الشارع الاسرائيلي اي
مظاهره وان كان ب يشارك بها بضعه افراد
يتم قمعها على الفور من قبل الشرطه
الاسرائيليه بتوجيهات من وزير الامن
القومي المسؤول عن الشرطه ايتمار بن كبير
وهذا تماما ما يحدث ايضا مع هذا النائب
عفر كسيف لمجرد انه عبر عن طلبه بوقف
الحرب على غزه والتوقيع على هذه العريضه
التي تقول بان اسرائيل تقوم باباده جماعيه
كانت ضده حمله واسعه اتهموه بانه يدعم
احداث السابع من اكتوب وبانه يدعم الارهاب
وبانه يدعم العنف ضد الاسرائيليين وعليه
عقدت هذه الجلسه ومن المتوقع في الساعات
القريبه المقبله ان يتم التصويت على عزل
هذا النائب في سابقه اولى في تاريخ
الكنيست شكرا جزيلا لك نجوان سمري
مراسلتنا من تلبيب